- I watched, I think at the time,
like every single coming
out video on YouTube.
Hearing their stories and
everything comforted me so much.
There are so many people
that I could like,
really, really, I would love
to meet and say thank you to.
(upbeat music)
I do like 10 push ups,
sometimes I'll do star jumps too
if I'm feeling like a bit crazy.
The first one that actually mattered to me
who has like since come out as
not straight is Miley Cyrus.
I remember she, when I
was like 13 or whatever
and watching Hannah Montana,
I thought she was like the
coolest person in the world,
and she wrote a song called
My Heart Beats For Love,
she said in an interview that it was about
her gay best friend,
and I was like oh my God, Miley
Cyrus has a gay best friend.
Why am I not that person?
And I was like, if everyone
in the world rejects me
I can just go become
friends with Miley Cyrus.
I would say, try not to stress.
I know that that is like,
it seems like such a silly thing to say,
but really, there are people in the world
who 1000% will love you
like just the way you are.
It came about with,
Alessia and I were mates,
and we had met a couple of times,
and I covered her song Here on the radio,
and then she covered my
song Youth on the radio,
and I texted her and I was like,
okay well I'm gonna one up you and cover,
I think I threatened her with Wild Things,
and she was like, well no,
let's do something official,
and I was like, sweet let's do it,
and she went into the studio,
and she recorded her verse on Wild,
and I like lost my mind.
I can't commit to anything stylistically
for the rest of my life,
so I would just get probably
super, super simple,
my family's names or initials,
or something like that.
The only way that I knew
I was ready to come out
was I was being driven crazy
by the fact that I was not out.
Every single time I was alone
with either of my parents
for a split second I was like,
oh my God, am I gonna do it now,
is this the time?
How can I get the
conversation to go there?
And it was literally driving me insane,
I thought I was going nuts.
It's so weird, 'cause
it's one of those things
that you build up, you know,
I had built this up for
like 15 years in my head,
and then it's like two
words and it's over.
Always put ketchup on my
mac and cheese, always.
I think I have to kind of
be aware of how much power
words can have,
and yeah, it makes me
consider everything that I say
before I say it,
because yeah, you know,
you can really help a lot of people,
or you can really, really mess things up,
and so, yeah just try
to be smart and helpful.
Firstly, ask his permission I recon,
and then, I mean, if he's down,
go all out,
pride flags, glitter,
obviously the playlist
is very important too,
like a lot of Madonna.
I love when people make like
these collaborative books.
I get these booklets, and
it's letters from a bunch
of different people,
and they warm my heart so much.
I love, love, love reading
them on the tour bus and stuff.
It's on my right, this one.
Definitely the writing, yeah.
I love, love, love,
love, love songwriting,
and that whole, you know,
I don't know, for me it's
like the most therapeutic
thing in the world.
I didn't realize how much
me hiding my sexuality
also meant that I hid like
a lot of just my identity
as a person.
I think I realize now I
was really, really scared
to you know, express
myself to like fashion,
or like certain music,
or like certain TV shows.
I was petrified that anyone
would ever think I was gay,
God forbid, and so once I got over that
I kind of could just let myself be.
I realized that yeah, it gets,
you know, I'm kind of a different person
than I thought I was.
Bye.